sweet ride
I knees is a new pair of wheels to test
the efficacy of duct-tape tires the team
starting off a little slower and
beginning with a bike here we go
given Jesse has built his own motorbike
on nights changing a bicycle wheel
presents no problems it's part of
building making grunt noises and we are
done
Wow engine skills we need to be
methodical about how we build our tire
I've taken some measurements of a
standard bicycle tire so that our
duct-tape tire can be modeled after it
will use 1/2 inch strips to fill the rim
and then full strips to make the height
with the specs the guys go to work and
canon has a surprising confession I've
never ridden a bike before don't go too
fast this isn't that bad you're going
too fast
this is pretty easy look mom no hands
several miles on a road to nowhere and
they have their duct-tape tire can yes
you have a duct tape tiger oh yeah
but will it provide a serviceable ride
to find out cue to comparative controls
first up regular wheels we put this Cup
on our bicycle and we filled it to the
top with water go after each set of
tires takes its turn around the course
up we're experiencing some spillage
we'll see how much water's been spilled
my water is beautiful this should give
us an indication of how smooth the ride
is between each test yeah first we
started off at 300 milliliters and now
we're around 270 alright let's swap over
the rims okay if the myth requires a
MacGyver style save are you ready for
this I must be crazy
then the real gauge of the duct-tape
success will be to see where it falls in
the spectrum between a regular tire
tires are really beautiful and nothing
at all
we lost the camera and all the wire this
is wire yeah you started at 300
milliliters and now you're down to 85
milliliters now now it's time to test
our duct tape tired and now with the old
in with the new
yeah she's ready to ride
three two one go
oh this isn't too bad so far so good
these duct tape tires not only look good
actually kind of smooth but they also
feel good
working a lot better than the rims like
it looks like she's pedaling slower just
because of how heavy they are
I don't even care how they perform I'm
just glad I'm off of rims it's a great
dudes and finish the results are in
these duct-tape tires are fantastic
Rachel did pretty well with the duct
tape tired we didn't lose much water
with the rims she didn't have much
traction so her back end kind of slid
out a little bit and that's why so much
water was lost I think duct tape tires
might be a viable solution